we the successors of a country and the
time
where a skinny black girl descended from
slaves and raised by a single mother can
dream
of becoming president only to find
herself
reciting for one amanda gorman made
history on wednesday
as the youngest inaugural poet in u.s
history
and yes we are far from polished
far from pristine but that doesn't mean
we are striving to form a union that is
perfect we are striving to forge
our union with purpose the 22 year old
read her own poem
titled the hill we climb at the
inauguration of president joe biden
and vice president kamala harris that
even
as we grieved we grew that even as we
hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
that we'll forever be tied together
victorious
not because we will never again know
defeat but because we will never
again so division the los
angeles native documented the moments
leading up to her time at the mic
on instagram say hey mom
hey the united states senate the
honorable doctor
that's amanda rehearsing on tuesday
having a moment of reflection to take it
all
in oh and that that's a pick with her
mom
and the obamas she admitted the whole
meeting had her deceased
she also posed with hillary and bill
clinton calling it the selfie of her
year
we've braved the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace amanda looked straight fire
rocking a yellow blazer and
gold hoop earrings fun fact
oprah magazine revealed those were a
gift from oprah people
yes oprah freaking winfrey
i'm proud of her for having the courage
to say it lady oh sent amanda those gold
hoops which feature hanging diamonds
and a bird cage a nod to dr maya angelou
who
of course wrote the book i know why the
caged bird sings
and spoke at the 1993 inauguration of
former president
bill clinton oprah took to instagram to
praise the young poet writing
quote i have never been prouder to see
another young woman rise
brava brava amanda gorman maya angelou
is cheering
and so am i it was really fun because we
all just burst into cheers
lin-manuel miranda also gave amanda
props on social media
she responded thanking the hamilton
creator and asking him
did you catch the two hamilton musical
references in the inaugural poem
i couldn't help myself his response you
were perfect
perfectly written perfectly delivered
every
bit of it as for how amanda's poem came
together
she revealed in an interview with cbs
this morning that she wrote it after
rioters stormed the u.s capitol building
on january
6th on the wednesday in which we saw the
insurrection at the capitol
that was the day that the poem really
came to life and i really put petal to
the metal
did that change the poem for you
definitely i wanted it to be a message
of
hope and unity and i think that
wednesday for me
really just underscored how much that
was needed
but to not turn a blind eye to the
cracks that really need to be filled
[Music]
you